motorcycle fatalities up 32 percent from
this time last year in our state but
there's training to help drivers prepare
before they head out on the roads 8 news
now reporter sally jeremy live near
sahara and rainbow with more on those
tips sally
brian experts say the pandemic has
sparked a huge interest in people
wanting to drive bikes as for top
classes for motorcycle fatalities are
alcohol involvement and
speed steve ritchie is the writing
academy manager at red rock
harley-davidson he says there's a huge
demand for people wanting to get a
motorcycle license richie says if you're
considering a motorcycle make sure you
get the proper education first there's
even a writing academy on site you know
just because your next-door neighbor
rides a motorcycle doesn't mean they can
teach you to ride a motorcycle so take
formal training get the education that
you need to be safe for not only for
yourself but for your family too ricci
estimates about 500 new riders will get
a license through the red rock
harley-davidson riding academy
back out here live richie says as gas
prices increase he believes we will
start to notice more motorcyclists
riding around the las vegas streets
sally haramiyo live local now